enjoy life
fiber to the home punishes people
upload and download files at the
speed of light a blu ray in 33
minutes on sign tv
three hundred photographs
58 seconds
the entire activity real time
always connected
innovation
faible gijon makes a new
group possible  of services contents and
applications
remote surgery
teleassistance
intelligent electrical grids
and smart grids
video surveillance systems
personal tv
video or a
clown's hand accomplished
online games
videoconferencing the days
grow your business
faster effective and
better quality communications
less traffic
telework
contact with the whole world
sustainability
thanks to fiber the future and moggi
fiber to the home council europe let's
create a brighter future